dear Oliver allow me to join your
colleagues in congratulating you on your
election as president of the European
economic and social committee
your experience and your commitment to
social fairness in the European project
are well known
and the committee is fortunate to have
you
what makes your work so important is the
strong Alliance that you nurture between
trade unions employers and Civil Society
it is a bond built on cooperation
and on solidarity
and it strengthens our society so I
would like to thank you all for
extending this Bond beyond our Union's
borders
to the Ukrainian people for example
who are fighting against the Russian
aggressor
and who are fighting for future with
European integration social fairness
and Economic Opportunity
the committee is also supporting
representatives in Belarus who dream of
democracy in their country too and
you're so right
we must do all we can to support our
neighbors who are standing up for
freedom for fairness and for a better
future for their children
because these are the values that bring
us all together as Democrats and
Europeans
to face these challenges we need also to
strengthen the bond between workers
innovators and reformers here at home
this is how we overcame the pandemic
together
and this is how we are now overcoming
the energy crisis
thanks to sound economic policy with a
strong social heart
and we need even more of that today
so the commission is working hard to
bring the European social Pillar To Life
we launched a new push for equality in
the workplace
with equal pay for equal work
with the child and youth guarantee
with a new care strategy with a fair
minimum wage
and with a proposal to protect platform
workers
because our social market economy is
based on a very simple idea
that Europe's greatest strength lies in
each and every one of us
and this is also the secret of Europe's
competitiveness
our green deal industrial plan is built
on the conviction that we can only
secure Europe's future prosperity
if we use all the levers of the social
Market
conducive regulation and funding are
important
but not enough
we also need skills for Quality jobs
and in a time of Labor shortages in key
areas
it is investments in people and they
know how
that drive the pace of our green and
digital transitions
and this is why we are pressing ahead
with the pact for skills
to conclude the commission looks forward
to working closely with the committee
and with you president de Oliver
not only can we strengthen the social
Dimension at the heart of Europe's
social market economy
but we can also nurture the
competitiveness and Innovation that
secures jobs and opportunity here in
Europe for our generation and for those
to come
thank you very much and all my best
wishes dear Oliver for your presidency